Back when I first started learning how to cook,
the. One of the first things I Learned how to cook correctly
was a roast chicken.
This is such a simple but useful skill to learn in the kitchen.
Chicken is so versatile. You can use this as a meal in itself,
or break it down to cook many other meals,
and then make some broth afterwards,
which then can be used to make soups,
gravies, and so much more.
We're gonna start with our chicken here
that I process myself. Now,
if you do process your own chicken,
make sure that the chicken rest in brine for a few hours.
And don't cook it to the next day.
You need to give it at least,
you know, six to 12 hours to pass rigor mortis.
If the chickens in rigor mortis
when you cook it, it's gonna be tough.
Then gonna salt the whole carcass,
even inside. You can also put a lemon inside.
I think this slows down the cooking time,
so I prefer not to do that.
I season my butter and it's.
And liberally coat the whole chicken in butter.
I have salt, pepper,
garlic, and thyme.
I did put some thyme inside the carcass as well.
With any chicken or Turkey,
if you stuff the inside of the carcass,
it's gonna slow down the cooking time.
Now, I roasted this chicken at 3 seventy five
for about an hour and 15 minutes.
I continue to check Depending on the weight of your bird,
you really need to check the temperature.
I use a digital thermometer.
The internal temperature needs to reach 1 sixty five.
So I'll pull the chicken out at 1:60.
Because it will continue to cook for a few minutes
and rise in temperature once you pull it out.
If you go over this temperature,
it's gonna start to dry the chicken out.
Now, I'm not handling this right out the oven.
I let the chicken rest for about 30 minutes
and cool down where I can handle it
and dismantle the chicken correctly.
This also lets the chicken trap in those juices and not to dry out.
And it doesn't burn your hands.
It's a lot easier to take the chicken apart when it's not piping hot.
Now I get to enjoy this beautifully roasted chicken.
And I can use the carcass to boil down
and make some broth for soups and stews.